okay so the topic of this video are
organic molecules now here's a table of
the four categories of organic molecules
carbohydrates proteins lipids and
nucleic acids I'm just going to
introduce organic molecules today and
then discuss carbohydrates I have
another video for proteins another for
lipids another for nucleic acids so
let's go ahead and get started so first
of all organic molecules are our
molecules that are built around carbon
maybe one atom of carbon maybe multiple
atoms of carbon and so here we have a
periodic table square of carbon and
there's something that's fairly unique
about carbon and I'll show you that in
just a moment but first of all carbon
has six protons if you recall from our
periodic table which means it also has
six electrons so why don't I draw the
six electrons of carbon remember I can
only draw two electrons in the first
level but then I can put the remaining
four electrons in the second level well
now we see why carbon is unstable
remember the second level of electrons
needs a total of eight but you can see
in the picture carbon only has four
electrons in the second level so carbon
is unstable and because carbon is
unstable it's going to bond probably up
to four different times and that's what
makes carbon unique most atoms do not
bond four times but carbon does and
because carbon bonds every single carbon
atom bonds of four times it's going to
carbon will often be the center of some
very complex molecules which I'll show
you in a little so when we go on into
organic molecules I want to mention that
molecules can be big and small and so a
small carbon molecule it's just a
general word for a small carbon molecule
is what we call a monomer now there are
various kinds of monomers for example
you may have heard of amino acids I mean
acids are a small organic molecule
they're a monomer but when you link one
monomer with another with another with
another into a big chain you get what's
called a polymer so polymers are large
complex chains of monomers so in my
example here we can see that a protein
is an example of a monomer and it's made
from a large collection of smaller amino
acids so just as I said a moment ago a
whole bunch of chain amino acids makes
up a larger protein the amino acids
individually are the monomers the
overall protein is the polymer here's
another example a bunch of simple sugars
a whole bunch of simple sugars are
monomers and when they're linked
together they make up a larger structure
called a complex sugar now this is going
to be more of what we talked about later
in the video because simple sugars and
complex sugars are carbohydrates and
eventually I'm going to get into
carbohydrates there's another type of
other organic molecule first of all you
see a whole bunch of nucleotides when
they bind together they make something
called a nucleic acid so nucleic acids
are a polymer and they're made up of a
bunch of monomers called nucleotides so
DNA and RNA are nucleic acids that are
made from nucleotides so when we look at
carbon there's carbon and each dot
represents the four dots the four
electrons that carbon has in its second
energy level I didn't draw the first
energy level for for simplicity so I'm
only focusing on the second energy level
of carbon so if I were to ask you is
carbon stable with only four electrons
in its outer layer I hope you know the
answers no well here's four atoms of
hydrogen hydrogen only has one total
electron that's it one total electron
there's four of them four hydrogen atoms
so look at these four hydrogen atoms are
any of them stable they only have one
electron in its first level I hope you
know that
the first level is supposed to hold two
so hydrogen's are not stable either so
when you look at all five of the atoms
the four hydrogen's in the one carbon
all of these atoms are unstable so what
do atoms do when they're unstable look
at this when atoms are unstable they
bond they bind and make molecules this
is a molecule by the name of methane ch4
one carbon four hydrogen's they share
electrons this would be an example of a
covalent bond and notice when they do
each individual atom is stable I
highlighted the hydrogen on the Left
it's stable because it's got two
electrons in the first level the bottom
hydrogen also stable because it has two
electrons and it only has one energy
level and energy level one can is full
and stable with two electrons the
hydrogen on the right same thing it has
two electrons its own and then a
borrowed one from carbon stable the
hydrogen on top also stable because it
has two electrons and two is all that's
required to make the first level stable
look at the carbon in the middle the
carbon in the middle has eight electrons
that two makes carbon stable because
remember eight is the desired number to
make the second level stable so when
they bond all the atoms become stable
but there you know there's a problem
when you draw these dot diagrams these
are called Lewis dot diagrams by the way
when you draw them they can be a little
time consuming so try this instead watch
this instead of dots simply add dashes
notice that each dash represents two
electrons so that we're going to be
drawn these more throughout the course
of this video and then my school so
here's a again what I mean by the dot
diagrams can be a little complex and so
this dot diagram with carbon in the
middle and four fluorines around the
outside is the same thing as this right
here this this dashed diagram much more
simpler
and so again just to remind you that one
- equals two electrons and so I
mentioned earlier because carbon can
bond up to four times it's going to
often be involved in some very complex
molecules well here's a very simple
example you saw this a moment ago of
methane you know if we look at all the
single dashes these are examples of
single bonds and if we focus on the
carbon in the middle focus on the carbon
in the middle you can see that there's
four dashes attached to the carbon in
the middle remember one dash is two
electrons so four dashes is eight
electrons this carbon is stable if we
look at a more complex example isooctane
here's a more complex example if we pick
a carbon from there any carbon that
carbon right there
how many electrons does that carbon have
notice there are four dashes coming off
of that carbon for a total of eight
electrons it's stable as are all the
other carbons I just chose that one
right there sometimes you can have
double dashes and these are what are
called double bonds it looks like an
equal sign and again if you that just
means that they share multiple electrons
and if we put the carbon any carbon how
about that carbon right there on the
right
how many dashes are attached to that
carbon you see four dashes remember one
dash is two electrons so four dashes is
eight electrons that carbon stable as
are all the other carbons because they
also have four dashes each well can
there be a triple bond yes here's an
example of a triple bond you can see
that there's a triple bond holding those
two carbons together if I ask you to
focus your attention on the carbon to
the left how many electrons does the
carbon on the Left have you see four
dashes attached to the carbon on the
left that's a total of eight electrons
that carbon is stable Carbon can also
form these ring structures you see a
variety of single bonds and double bonds
in this diagram and if you pick any
carbon pick that carbon right there you
can see that that carbon has four dashes
attached to it for a total of eight
pick any carbon you'll notice they all
have four dashes for a total of eight
electrons okay so that was a quick
introduction of carbon and organic
molecules but now I want to specifically
focus on a type of organic molecules
known as carbohydrates carbohydrates are
readily available in the foods that we
eat pastas and fruits for examples are
high in carbohydrates now when you look
at the chemical structure of a
carbohydrates you generally are going to
see a pattern carbohydrates are made
from carbon hydrogen and oxygen and
usually you're going to see a 1 to 2 to
1 ratio for every one carbon you'll find
2 hydrogen's for every one carbon you'll
find one oxygen a great example is in
the picture c6 h-12 o-6 that's the
formula for glucose and if you look
there's six carbons 12 hydrogens and six
oxygens so there's double the amount of
hydrogen's compared to carbon and oxygen
well here's another example this is the
example of the molecule called fructose
notice it too has a formula of c6 h-12
o-6 so glucose and fructose have the
exact same formulas but the the atoms
are just arranged in a different
configuration by the way these are
molecules called isomers when they have
the exact same chemical equation
chemical formula but just arranged in a
different combination but notice glucose
and fructose they each have a 1 to 2 to
1 ratio of carbon hydrogen and oxygen I
mentioned earlier that simple sugars can
form larger complex sugar
well the scientific name for a simple
sugar is called a monosaccharide so a
monosaccharide is a simple sugar they're
the same thing and when one
monosaccharide bonds with another with
another with another with another with
another we get a larger object called a
poly saccharide so a complex sugar is
the same thing as a polysaccharide
poly saccharide is just more of the
scientific term for a complex sugar so
complex sugars are made from smaller
simple sugars and so how do these
monosaccharides how do these simple
sugars bind together well I want to
introduce you to a process called
dehydration synthesis and you think of
what it means to be dehydrated if
something's dehydrated it means that
it's lacking or it's lost water now
watch what happens between
monosaccharides one and monosaccharide
to watch this in-between monosaturated
one and two water is removed the removal
of water bonds the monosaccharide one
and monosaccharide two together they're
now sharing one of the oxygens the same
thing happens between monosaccharides 2
& 3 watch this a dehydration synthesis
reaction is going to occur the removal
of water will bond monosaccharide 3 to
monosaccharide 2 and so now we have this
larger molecule this is all one molecule
in my diagram it's just made from three
smaller monosaccharides so I want to
bring up and go into a little more
detail with the dehydration synthesis
reaction so in dehydration synthesis as
I just mentioned water a molecule of
water is going to be removed here we
have to in this picture two
monosaccharides and notice how the Oh H
is have been highlighted in red well
when we look at the the next part of
this chemical reaction we're going to
show you how these two Mount of
saccharides bind together so dehydration
synthesis is the process where larger
molecules are built from smaller
molecules if we look at again this
diagram monomer number one plus monomer
number two through the removal of water
through the removal of water they are
going to bond to make a polysaccharide
actually this would just be what's
called a disaccharide because there's
two of them bonded together but if there
is more than two we call it a poly
saccharide
so this is again how large molecules are
built what about the opposite the
opposite of a dehydration synthesis
reaction is a hydrolysis reaction and
this is where large molecules are broken
down into small molecules
it's called hydrolysis hydro cuz water
is going to be added lysis simply means
to break apart so water is going to help
break apart a larger molecule so this is
going to cause larger polymers to break
into small monomers and in the diagram
we see a polysaccharide actually this
would begin to be a disaccharide on the
left because there's two monomers that
make this together but when we look at
the equation plus h2o right in the
middle of the equation with the addition
of water that's gonna that's going to
break that polysaccharide into monomer
number one and monomer number two so a
larger molecule gets broken down into
two smaller ones I have a nice animation
of this in just a moment so this is the
way that all organic molecules are
either built they are either built by
dehydration synthesis or broken down or
reduced they're reduced and broken down
by hydrolysis so here's the the
animation that I I said a moment ago
that I think will help visualize this at
the top dehydration synthesis with the
removal of water with the removal of
water
those three monosaccharides have been
bonded together to make a larger
polysaccharide when I look at the bottom
of the animation for hydrolysis with the
addition of water that large
polysaccharides now been broken down
into three individual monosaccharides so
they are really just the opposites of
one another okay so I mentioned that
carbohydrate polymers go by the name of
polysaccharides so remind ourselves that
a polysaccharide is a long chain of
monosaccharides well there's three
polysaccharides that I want to give
special attention to just because
they're quite important in the world of
biology the first is a polysaccharide by
the name of starch and starch is a plant
sugar so you only find it in plants you
don't find starch and animal meat or
fish or eggs or anything so it's a sugar
it's a complex sugar a polysaccharide
that is uh that is converted and stored
by plants and so I'll touch on that in
just a moment but if we look at the
picture here starch very simplistically
in this diagram is made from five
monomers of glucose if we look at its
actual chemical diagram there you can
see it's it's made from five monomers
five glucose sugars make up starch foods
that are high in starch would be
potatoes would be breads and rice so
again potatoes will store their sugar in
the form of starch so the next
polysaccharide I want to mention is
called glycogen you know here's a
picture of a fairly detailed picture of
glycogen in its animals version of
starch so you don't find the y Kajin and
plants you only find it in animals and
we store this for it for energy we often
store it in our body stores in our liver
and in our muscles you know this is a
fairly detailed diagram but there's
actually 30,000 glucose monomers that
make up glycogen so it is a fairly large
molecule now I mentioned a moment ago
that it's often stored in the liver and
it's stored in the muscles and whenever
are whenever we're low on blood sugar so
if we've been exercising and working
really hard and we're low on blood sugar
our liver and muscles will release this
stored glycogen into our blood to raise
our sugar level back up and the last one
I want to mention is called cellulose
now here's a diagram of a plant cell you
might remember from earlier that plants
haven't have a cell membrane you can see
it's labeled yellow all
so called the plasma membrane but plants
have an outer boundary to them as well
called the cell wall the cell wall is
made from cellulose a very tough very
fibrous molecule and so foods that are
high in cellulose would be celery if you
just know from your experience with
biting and chewing celery it's very hard
too hard to chew hard to digest and very
fibrous tough plant because it's full of
cellulose so cellulose is a very
important component in the cells the
cell wall of plants so if you're in my
honors biology class I am going to give
you your free response your essay
question for the chapter to test and
here it is now the only thing you're not
going to know is what version you're
going to get half of you will randomly
get version a and I'm going to ask you
to diagram the process of hydrolysis
half of you will get version B I'm going
to ask you to diagram the process of
dehydration synthesis now keep in mind
they're really just opposites of one
another so yeah we'll talk more about
this in class but you can always pause
the video and and try to solve this at
home in the days leading up to leading
up to the test and we'll talk more about
this in class so if you're watching the
video pause this and try to answer these
questions if you're in my biology class
pause the video and you know write your
answers on a separate sheet of paper I'd
be happy to check them before school or
after school for accuracy so go ahead
and pause the video good luck